great so let's get started so the the
plan for today is to
really primarily talk about multitask
learning but then we'll also go over
some of the basics of transfer learning
as well
in multi-test learning we'll talk about
the problem statement we'll talk about
model architectures objectives and
optimization we'll talk about some of
the challenges of multitask learning and
then we'll go through a case study
from a multi-task youtube recommendation
system
uh that was actually quite recent from a
paper that was from last year
uh we'll also try to take a short break
after the challenges between the case
study like a couple minutes although for
a long time we might skip that it
depends on how many questions there
and then lastly the goals is by the end
of the lecture
you should be able to kind of understand
the key design decisions when building
multi-task learning systems understand
the differences between multi-house
learning and transfer learning and also
understand some of the basics of
transfer learning
cool so that's for the plan for today
so
um
for some notation that i'll be using
throughout the lecture and also
likely in future lectures as well so uh
we'll be considering uh multitask
learning with neural networks for
for the lecture today
and the we'll use x to denote the input
why to denote the
output um or the label
and
uh this may be something you may the
input may be something like an image for
example the image
of a of a tiger
and then the output may be a probability
distribution over what you think the
label is whether you think it's a tiger
a tiger cat a link such a cat and so
forth
um or the input might be something like
the title of a paper um maybe you want
to know
whether or not given a title you should
review that paper maybe you don't like
reviewing papers that are really long
and so you want to train a neural
network to estimate what the length of
the paper would be based off of the
title of the paper
so the input could be things like images
text
really a wide range of unstructured
inputs and the output
is typically something a little bit
simpler but it's something more related
to what you care about
uh we'll use data to denote the
parameters of the neural network
uh and then we'll denote the kind of the
function that this neural network
represents as f parameterized theta of y
given x
cool so that's kind of the basics and uh
if you were to do single task learning
such as predicting the label of an image
then we would typically assume that we
have a data set of input output pairs
and then we would formulate some loss
function that may correspond to the
negative log likelihood such as a
cross-entropy loss or mean squared error
and then try to minimize the
this objective function
and specifically search over the
parameters data
um and so your your loss function might
look something like this and then
typically you optimize this loss
function with stochastic gradient
descent um or your other kind of your
favorite optimizer
okay so now let's revisit the question
of what is a task and this will allow us
to set up the multitask learning problem
so
and we'll talk about this actually a
little bit more formally than what we
did last lecture
so we'll define a task as
a set of three things uh
p of x p of y given x and the loss
function
and in particular these
distributions p are going to are
representing essentially the data
generating distributions
i is indexing the task
and uh
each of these tasks will have a
corresponding data set that is drawn
from the data generating distributions
and typically you assume that you have a
train set and a test set where you
trade on the train set and then
during evaluation you evaluate on the
test set
uh we'll also use di as shorthand for d
train i throughout the rest of this
lecture
just to simplify some of the notation
okay so this is going to be our formal
definition of a task now let's look at a
few examples of what tasks might look
like
so
one version of a multi-task learning
problem would be multi-task
classification
where maybe you want to be able to
classify different kinds of objects
and in this setting the loss function is
going to be the same across all of the
tasks it might be
log negative log likelihood um
or or cross-entropy loss or something
uh and some examples of this is maybe
you want to be able to
recognize different uh different
handwriting characters for different
languages and different languages will
correspond to different tasks
or maybe you want
a spam filter and different tasks will
correspond to different users and
they're essentially in both of these
settings the distribution over
x and the distribution over y given x
are going to be different for different
tasks because different users have
different kinds of emails
and also different languages write
characters in different ways
but what will be kind of the same across
tasks will be the um will be the loss
function
so this is kind of one example of a
multi-test learning problem
another example of a multi-task learning
problem is what's called multi-label
learning
uh in this setting the
loss function and the
distribution over x are going to be the
same across tasks
and it's what is this distribution p of
y given x that's going to be different
uh so an example of this is trying to
uh
recognize different attributes of faces
so maybe one label corresponds to
recognizing whether someone's wearing
sunglasses or whether someone's wearing
a hat or another label is recognizing
someone's eye color or something like
that
so in this the
basically the data set that you have
both the data generating distribution
over x and also often
the inputs x in your training data set
are identical but what's different is
you have different labels
okay and then kind of an example of
scene understanding that actually comes
up a lot is when you want to understand
a scene uh or an image of a scene you
typically may want to predict the depth
you may want to predict some some key
points you may want to predict the
surface normals uh
each of these different uh
each of these different labels
correspond to different tasks
okay
and someone's asking me to talk a little
bit slower so i'll try to do that
the
last question is when might the loss
function
vary across tasks
so in both of these first two examples
the loss function is the same across
tasks and what's really differing is the
data generating distribution
um there's a few settings that where we
might see the loss function vary across
tasks as well one might be where we have
kind of some labels that are discrete
and some labels are continuous and you
may want to have different false
functions for different kinds of data
different kinds of labels
and the second scenario might be if you
care about multiple different metrics of
your performance
maybe for your spam filter you want it
to be accurate but you also
um
maybe you also want it to
treat different emails in different ways
maybe
the way that it like classifies spam and
and in him you may want to kind of
uh label things in different ways maybe
another example of this is uh that we'll
actually see in the real world example
uh for recommendation systems is maybe
you want it to be able to
um
maybe you have a metric that it cares
about uh kind of user satisfaction
and another thing that cares about how
long the user is um
how long the user is paying attention to
a video
okay any questions on on these example
problems
yeah
um can you explain a little more about
the pro language handwriting recognition
um like are you trying to recognize
handwriting for different characters for
different languages at the same time
yeah so what this looks like is you may
um maybe you have
characters
written in uh
in japanese and also in uh
like arabic like english
language
and you want a network that can both
both kind of recognize recognize both
languages rather than a single system
that can recognize um
just one of the languages
so in this case you're going to have a
different
key of x and a different p of y given x
because the characters will look
different and also the labels will be
different maybe you'll have
output you'll have kind of an output of
0 to
25 for
kind of english
letters and then maybe you'll have
i don't know
labels from zero to
a much larger number for japanese
characters
great
do you have a question
um just want to clarify one thing i
think everything on the right half of
the slides look good but on the left
half i just want to make sure i
understand for the task p i of x and p
of i of y given x um what are the
examples for those like just uh to put
those in perspective like what was your
scenario what what are these exactly
yeah that's a good question
so
p i of of x so this is um
this is essentially the distribution
over inputs and the distribution of
labels given inputs
and so
in the example of
um
of japanese characters for example
there's typically you have some data of
like handwritten japanese characters
and p of x will be
essentially the distribution that
generates that data
okay
kind of the manifold of
of those images and p of y given x is uh
this kind of underlying the function
underlying whether a label um kind of a
label given a certain input uh typically
in practice you don't actually have to
deal with these these generating
distributions you only deal with the
data sets themselves
useful to think about the generating
distributions though because this is we
assume that the kind of the transit and
the tests that are both drawn iid from
those data generating distributions
okay okay that makes sense thank you so
much
so in this modded
learning we are discussing here does the
model know which task is currently
performing or this is negative
prediction for all tests a test
yeah that's a good question we'll get to
that um like in like one or two slides
but typically the model is told what
task it wants to do
quick follow-up question to the question
was the function of the i in the pi do
next is this for a specific training
example
yeah so the i is indexing i'm just using
that to index different tasks uh so one
task will have one index the other test
will have another index um
and i guess part of the reason why i
mentioned that is in like multi-task
classification for example
where
li is the same across tasks then you can
actually write a task
as
as actually being p i
of x
p i of y given x and then just a single
loss function that isn't indexed by i
um
so i'm just using it to index different
tasks and if something doesn't vary
across tasks then you don't actually
need the index
multitask setup where
we have different alphabets conceptually
why is that considered multitask why
don't we treat this simply
instead of having alphabet of 26 letters
we have an alphabet of say 50 letters
awareness
letters from both alphabets and a single
data generating distribution
uh
and single
by giving x
yeah that's a good question so
like we mentioned in the previous
lecture in multitask learning problems
you can typically always represent it as
just a single task problem by taking the
kind of the data set and having this be
equal to
having a single data set be equal to the
union of all of the individual data sets
and likewise as kind of the loss
function as the sum over
the individual loss functions
um so basically in all these situations
there is a way to kind of turn it into a
single task learning problem
uh and as we'll see in the next few
slides there are scenarios where it's
useful to treat it as a multi-task
learning problem
by kind of changing the architecture the
network architecture in different ways
or leveraging the structure or changing
the optimization
um so i think in the last lecture as
well you mentioned that um it's either
equivalent or at least faster or
efficient to do it this way
i can see how this is more efficient but
is it or i can see how this is faster
but is it always uh going to give us
better results to train it individually
uh to train it all together versus
training it uh individually
yeah so we'll talk about this a bit
later but the kind of the short answer
is that it depends on the application
there are some situations where it's
actually better to treat these as
separate tasks and train them completely
independently and there are other
situations where it's helpful to train
them all together
all right thank you
do you still have a question or did you
just leave your hand up okay great
can you unraise your hand um i think you
can lower your hand i can also lower it
for you yes
okay thank you
okay
great so
[Music]
the
let's move on to the next slide actually
there's a question in the chat isn't
multitask classification also
multi-label learning um
you could also view multitask
classification as
in some ways a form of multi-label
learning i wanted to special case
multi-label learning because p of x is
the same across tasks whereas in
multi-task classification is typically
not the same across tasks
okay great so
let's actually move on to how we
go about training this bottle so
one thing that we typically assume
for the different tasks in addition to
what we described before is this notion
of a task descriptor which i'll denote
with zi
uh and we'll somehow condition the model
we'll feed the model this task
descriptor as input and this essentially
tells the model what task it's trying to
do
now
uh and then the model becomes something
that's actually conditioned on ci
so
for example if we are again thinking
about you're trying to figure out what
paper whether to accept a paper to
review or not maybe you're given the
title of the paper and you want to know
other things like you want to know the
length of the paper you want to know a
summary of the paper um you maybe
want the neural network to write the
review for the paper as well so that you
don't have to write it
um maybe these are the different tasks
that you want to do
then in this example the task descriptor
could correspond to a few different
things
it could correspond to a one hot
encoding of the task index which would
essentially just be
if the task index is two
then it would be
um then it would be a vector that looks
like this where there is a one in the
second location if the task index was
three then the one would be in the third
position and so forth
uh zi could also be
other metadata that you have so
for example
in a personalization example where
different tasks correspond to different
users then zi might contain information
or features or attributes of that user
it may also correspond to a language
description of the task so in this
example that we talked about before um
maybe a language description of each of
these tasks might be give me tell me how
many pages the paper is or
give me a summary of the paper or can
you write a review of the paper
these would kind of give it some
more structured information about what
you're asking it to do and this would
also be similar to a question answering
system for example
uh and then it also may be some other
more formal specifications of the task
as well uh and there are some
applications where that may make sense
okay
yeah uh my question is regarding to the
spam classification example
and in the case of spam classification
the output space is the same for all the
users right it's either spam or not spam
so when we are conditioning on the
user's features then uh wouldn't this
like resolve to a single task
classification problem instead of a
multi multitask classification problem
because we are already conditioning on
the features of the users
and the answer is the same
yeah in many ways when you do actually
start conditioning on this task
descriptor it does kind of
come to a single task learning problem
as we'll talk about in the next few
slides there's a number of design
choices with regard to how do you
incorporate this test descriptor into
the problem what sort of architecture do
you use and also alternative ways to
optimize um optimize the model as well
thank you
hi um i'm wondering
for tests like the um
identifying characters of different
languages
i understand like kind of training set
you can give a task descriptor saying oh
this language is this this language
isn't but how would you then go to like
an end result where you want it to
detect the language and then classify
the character
yeah so if you don't if you
want it to detect the language itself
and you don't want to give it
information about what language it is
then you could also choose not to
condition on
zi
and in that setting you may the kind of
the architectures that we'll talk about
in the following slides
wouldn't necessarily apply because you
want to detect what the task is itself
but some of the optimization techniques
that we'll talk about would also would
still apply
thank you
okay so
um once you set up this architecture
then the vanilla objective that you're
trying to optimize is what we talked
about before where you just
take all of the loss functions for your
individual tasks
sum them and
minimize the
summed objective
uh and that's kind of this is really
like the the basics so like this is
this is kind of all with multitask
learning um at the very basic level
now like i mentioned before there's a
lot of design decisions with regard to
the model the objective and the
optimization
for example how should we condition on
the task descriptor
what objective should we use is this is
this vanilla objective the best option
or are there other good options
and also how do we optimize our
objective
so the vanilla option for optimization
would be to use sgd or atom um but there
are also another other somewhat delicate
design choices there as well
okay so these are kind of the things
that we'll talk about next we'll talk
about
uh how the model should be conditioned
on z and also what parameters of the
model should be shared and not shared
we'll then talk about the objective and
talk about the optimization
but first let's talk about the model
so
the model um
the kind of the first question of the
model is how should the model be
conditioned on the task
and let's first assume that z is the one
hot task index like i had described
before
so i have a question for you
which is how should you condition on the
task if you want the tasks to share as
little information as possible
and if you want to give a shot at
answering this question
please raise your hand
um could you use the one hot index to
branch off into separate
uh neural networks for like each task
that would that would share as little as
well yeah exactly so
yeah so if you basically want each of
the tasks to share as little as possible
then what you could do is you can
basically have three completely separate
networks and use the one hot task
identifier to basically choose which
neural network choose which branch you
want it to
uh
output
and
then do
multiplicative gating where you
basically take each of the outputs of
each of these independently trained
neural networks with completely separate
weights
and pass that into this function here
that basically
iterates over each of the tasks and sees
whether
the task is the
task indicated by z and multiply that by
the output
um you can also do what we mentioned
which is basically how the skating
happened at the beginning of the network
as well and uh either like pass in all
zeros for example uh
and do basically have uh
have something like x equals uh the sum
over
the index over z equals j
times x
um
into each of the networks that would
also be equivalent
and so one of the things that you'll
note here is that if you take this
architecture that gives you this y as
output if you back propagate into the
network gradients and train the whole
network for all these tasks
um maybe if you're doing if your current
task is task two then the gradients for
all these other branches will be zero
because of this gating right here
any questions does that make sense
my question is kind of related to the
previous slide so
um
how do you wait across these multiple
tasks so suppose you have like
uh each of the tasks don't have the same
amount of data for example or
some other issues so how do you wait
across these different tasks so that one
task is not
you know bringing training on other ones
yeah we'll talk about the waiting when
we talk about the objective after we're
done talking about the model so just uh
we'll we'll talk about that soon okay
hi another question so um i i see what
you did here it makes it makes sense my
question is what's the benefit of doing
it this way because it feels like it
wouldn't do that much better than the
baseline of just one neural network
trained on this task is maybe you want
to ensemble like the outputs of all of
them and have more heavily weight the
one whose task matches our input task
i'm just trying to see how this is a
little bit better
yeah so
this isn't necessarily something that
you want to do um this is more kind of
an illustrative example of how
your choice of conditioning on z
connects to your choice of the
architecture um
so yeah and generally this may not be
something that you want to do we'll talk
about situations where you when you may
want to do this later
but in practice you may want to share a
lot more between the tasks okay okay
thank you chelsea
great i'm going to go through a couple
more of the slides before going through
going to question because i think that
that might um
maybe you might answer some questions
but i'll get back to you in in a few
slides
okay um
right so this basically corresponds to
independent training within like a
single
neural network architecture
with no shared parameters
okay now the other extreme that you
could consider
is
one where you
basically just uh
add the z like concatenate it into the
network
um at one point in the architecture this
could be at the beginning this could be
um in the middle towards the end
uh and if you simply just concatenate
the uh
z with the activations at one of the
layers
then
basically all of the parameters of the
network are shared um so this is kind of
like the other extreme from what we
talked about before
uh and i guess one thing worth noting is
that if z is still your one hot index
then technically also the the parameters
directly following z uh will not be
shared uh
because the if z whoops um
if z is a one hot vector and you're
taking like your activations
a and your
one hot vector here and you have say
like zero one one zero then basically
each of the
you then have a large matrix w right
here
then the um
actually this is typically the other way
around but basically the um half of the
matrix w will contain either rows or
columns depending on how you put it as
will contain task specific parameters
because each of the parameters that are
multiplied by this index right here will
be specific to that task
but other than
half of this w matrix everything else in
the network will have shared parameters
um and so this kind of gives you a
somewhat alternative architecture or
alternative view on the multi-task
architecture
which is essentially think about instead
of thinking about conditioning on z
think about your parameters and
splitting those parameters into shared
parameters and task-specific parameters
and if you do this then you can
write out your objective as something
like this where you have again your
summation over tasks
and the
and what this objective is doing is
simply
making it clear that task specific
parameters theta i
are only going to be optimized with
respect to the task
with respect to the objective li and
they won't be optimized when you're
using other
other
loss functions
and it turns out that basically choosing
how to condition on this task descriptor
zi is equivalent to
choosing uh how and where to share
parameters
um yeah and the way that you can see
this is if you take a kind of a simple
architecture
uh say
you have a simple architecture that
looks like this where you have a couple
layers and then you split off
into
split off into two different heads
this will call this y1 and y2
then you could consider basically
each of the parameters here as your
shared parameters
each of the parameters here as task
specific parameters for task two and
likewise the parameters up here are
going to be task specific for
uh task one this is kind of one way to
view how and where to share parameters
you can also equivalently view this as a
network that simply
uh
conditions on z in a very particular
multiplicative way where you basically
gate
the two different outputs
of this model
so for example you set the prediction y
to be equal to
z i dotted with
uh maybe you call this a1 and a2 dotted
with the vector a1 and a2
okay um
looks like we have a few questions at
this point so do you have a question
okay
yeah
i didn't clearly
yeah so
in this architecture on the right for
example
um this corresponds to one architecture
where we're basically conditioning on zi
and the way that we're conditioning on
zi is in a multiplicative way where it's
essentially gating um which output you
use a1 or a2 so this architecture is
essentially just one way to condition on
zi where you have different branches of
the architecture and zi is choosing
which branch to use
and this architecture on the left
is one way to view kind of the top
point of view where you have shared
parameters and task-specific parameters
um and i guess one thing in here is that
on the right it's kind of not clear that
these are actually task specific
parameters that are only optimized for
test two that's a little bit less view
and this a little bit less clear in this
view and a little bit more clear in the
in the other view
uh can you explain again how a grading
descent works with
into different branches
yeah so the basically um
the objective here will correspond
you'll basically take um this objective
compute the gradients um and you'll note
that the gradient of this objective here
is equal to basically the gradient
um with respect to the shared parameters
and the task specific parameters
of loss one
plus the gradient of the shared
parameters and the task-specific
parameters for task two
of
of l2 uh-oh
i think my pen pencil ran out of
batteries um
and so
you compute these two gradients and then
when you run gradient descent you're
going to update the shared parameters
using the sum of these two gradients and
you'll update the top specific
parameters with the
um with the first term and the second
term separately so the test specific
parameters for task one will only be
updated by the first gradient and the
task specific parameters for task two
will only be updated with the second
gradient here
in practice with most deep learning
libraries they can basically handle this
for you they can figure out
which
um
how each parameters will be updated but
it is useful to know kind of um
what's happening under the hood that
basically this
that for example this kind of bottom
layer right here is only going to be
updated with regard to
gradients from task two
cool and then
um what happens if i have let's say like
overlapping data sets for the different
tasks so let's say that i have you know
task one is
um
you know detect uh some buildings or
something sorry i'm using my experience
list like task one and task two have
like slightly different data sets uh
because um you know you may your
labeling process may not be
comprehensive for like all tasks that
you want to do um in that situation one
of the over like the wouldn't the images
or training examples that um you have
that multiple data sets sort of have a
disproportionate impact on the shared
vector on the shared component of the
parameters um and how do you kind of
deal with that
yeah so
to deal with that sort of thing what you
can do is
um when sampling the data try and
basically uh
don't over sample don't basically double
sample for tasks that have shared data
um
so for example one thing you could do is
just sample from your dates from your
data set as it is and then back
propagate whatever losses you have for
those data points
um although there is a bit of a tricky
there's a bit of a trade-off there too
because if you do that maybe if one task
is over represented then your other task
will not get enough gradient data and
it's actually quite usually often quite
useful to stratify
um your batches to have an equal amount
of data for each task
let's turn it off keep in mind
hey i just wanted to do a quick
legislative question can you post these
annotated slides after the lectures
um i can we'll post the video which will
include the annotations unfortunately
keynote doesn't save the annotations but
i can also try to look into um
how we might try to export the
annotations afterwards
thanks yes please
okay great
so
um
we kind of went over the basics of
conditioning now we'll talk about a few
common choices uh of of conditioning so
one choice that we talked about before
was concatenation-based conditioning
where you take your input you take some
activations of the model then you
concatenate your
uh your zi with the activations or maybe
you concatenate it with the input
directly
and then you pass that through a neural
network
so this is a very common choice
uh another way that you could do this is
with additive conditioning where you
take the
um
the
the conditioning representation you
maybe pass it through a linear layer or
something to get something that's the
size of your activations or the size of
your input and then you add that
to the input
um
so these are kind of two choices uh it
turns out these first two choices are
actually equivalent
um in terms of what the model expresses
i'm curious if anyone has thoughts on
why
concatenation and additive conditioning
our equivalent
and if you have an idea raise your hand
yeah i think i can only have some idea
from a very high level i think from a
very high level both of these methods
answers
use the condition or
task descriptor c as an additional
feature
okay so they're both using it as
an additional feature so that is uh
that's correct but maybe there's a more
specific answer
do you have an idea
i'll be using the second case you pass
the zi's through a linear layer before
adding them so those
weights could be
um
implicitly also learned by the linear
layer that you have in case one
in a section of that linear layer is
specific to
the part of the full concatenated array
that corresponds to z eyes and when you
add them in the output you get the exact
same thing
yeah exactly so kind of visually what
this looks like is if you
um
you can essentially view this linear
layer as the same as the weights of the
kind of
half of this linear layer right here
and visually what this looks like is if
you
basically take the concatenated version
and apply the fully connected layer or
the linear layer right after that what
that looks like is taking this half of
the matrix and applying that to the
first half of the vector which was the
input and taking this half of the weight
matrix and applying that to the
um
the zi right here
so
[Music]
basically when you uh yeah when you
apply this linear this linear layer or
this fully connected layer you end up
getting something you end up getting
this these two completely independent
halves of that layer and then you add
them when doing the matrix vector
multiplication to get the result and so
this addition right here um
i basically is the same as the addition
when you're adding right here
okay so this is something essentially to
keep in mind
with regard to the conditioning
uh there's also a few other
architectures that we briefly mentioned
by multihead architecture before and
that is something that's also a common
choice for architecture where you have
some shared features that produce a
shared representation of the input and
then you branch off then to specific
layers
another choice is to use multiplicative
conditioning which we also talked a bit
about before where you
take your your zi
um you maybe pass it through a linear
layer or you um
or you directly multiply it with uh the
input to produce the output this would
be like one layer of the network
uh and as we talked about before there
are kind of close relationships between
multiplicative conditioning
and uh branching like multihead
architectures uh when zi corresponds to
a one hot vector and you're multiplying
directly
um and so yeah
one reason why my multiplicative might
be a good idea is that for an individual
layer it's more expressive than simply
adding or concatenating um of course at
the neural network level because neural
networks are universal function
approximators it isn't necessarily going
to be more expressive overall they're
probably both going to be equally
expressive if you have a deep enough
neural network
but for each individual layer you do get
more expressive power
um and then of course it also is closely
related to this gating and branching
idea that we talked about before
so in some ways multiplicative
conditioning generalizes independent
networks independent heads and so forth
okay let's go to a few of the questions
i'm going to assume that you had your
hand up from before
do you have a question or is that also
from
before the question is like copy
[Music]
um if you also have a non-linearity then
they're not like
like exactly exactly equivalent but um
depending on how that non-linearity
works it may also still be able to
represent the same thing
just uh just to confirm so if you have
like a value for example then in one
case
um you you might mask uh some negative
things and then when you add those both
the inputs will be negative and so you
have a zero overall but when you
concatenate them you have two zeros in
two different places and you know
depending on which you know if both of
them are not negative at the same time
yeah so if you either if you add values
in different places you won't get
exactly the same architecture
the i guess part of the reason why i was
bringing this up is that um this
suggests that the expressive power of
these two kinds of conditioning is very
similar um whereas when you move towards
multiplicative conditioning uh you get
more expressive power than when you're
adding or concatenating
can you actually uh
can you explain why uh multiplicative
conditioning is a generalization and has
a stronger generalization
um so i'm not saying that it has a
stronger generalization i'm saying that
the multiplicative conditioning
um it's you can view it as kind of a
more general way to then
simply forming independent networks and
independent heads so one instantiation
of multiplicative conditioning produces
this architecture um but multiplicative
conditioning can also represent a wide
range of other kinds of architectures uh
and and gating mechanisms
as well but it doesn't necessarily lead
to
better generalization isn't it the other
way around that the multi-head is a
better generalization
because in three segments and you just
go you know
so a multiplicative conditioning
architecture can represent this um i
guess it kind of depends on where you
put the multiplicative conditioning but
it can represent this exactly um but
because by nature of looking at this
gating mechanism where you're basically
taking zi and dotting it with the output
of each of these models
sounds good
yeah actually i just was confused about
uh why multiplicative condition will be
more expressive for later
if there's any interest in them yeah i
guess the intuition is that the um if
you use additive conditioning at the
individual layer it can't represent um
multiplication
uh the
yeah whereas at the i mean at the entire
network level it can represent that
because it could essentially um when you
kind of for example if you concatenate
things together then the neural network
the next the next couple layers of the
neural network can represent the
multiplicative can represent the
multiplication function um but the at
the individual layer the additive uh
cannot represent
multiplication
to answer your question
uh yeah thank you
yeah i had a question about uh
multi-year architecture as well as
multiplicative conditioning i'm not a
hundred percent sure how is multi-headed
architecture a conditional architecture
like we are not specifically
conditioning that on something right it
will always output um it will always
predict uh
like three tasks of three tasks right
yeah so um you can view it as a um
as a as a choice of conditioning in the
sense that if uh z i equals um is
basically like
zero zero one for example you basically
pass the input through all three heads
and then
gate it by this
this
zi right here then it will only give you
the output of task c
um if you basically have a one a two a
three dot dot um so take the dot product
between this output and zi which is a
multi form of multiplicative
conditioning then this will give you the
the corresponding output for the
corresponding head
okay and then in multiplicative
conditioning uh do we always have to
select from one or the other or can it
be like a
a continuous function
like instead of inputting a one-hot
encoder we're not encoded values we're
it can be continuous and if you if you
pass it through a linear layer then that
will allow it to represent a lot of
other things beyond just the one hot
vector
okay thank you
uh i'll take one more question from
[Music]
uh yeah uh i had a question about
attention uh i can't really say i
understand attention too well but i was
wondering if that's a way of
implementing multiplicative conditioning
and also if that's
a way of getting a more dense
representation of the task information
yeah that's a good question um attention
in many ways boils down to a dot product
uh so in that sense it is a way to
implement this dot product right here um
although i guess this isn't quite a dot
product because it um
because it's actually just like a
multiplication there isn't a summation
over over the dimensions
um
i'm not sure i haven't thought about
that i haven't given that too much
thought um
but yeah you could view kind of a form
of attention potentially as uh
as one way to condition as well
that segues nicely into the next slide
which is that there actually are a
number of other more complex choices
that you can think about with regard to
conditioning or network architectures as
well here's just a few of them
um there are kind of a wide range of
other other approaches that the
literature has produced as well um often
trying to just target a specific domain
like computer vision
um or or settings where you would expect
to have kind of looking at relationships
between
objects or tasks or something like that
um
the other thing is
unfortunately the design choices of the
architecture and conditioning are a lot
like neural network architecture tuning
in general which is that they tend to be
fairly problem dependent they're often
largely guided by intuition or
domain specific knowledge of the problem
and in many ways they're i think
currently more of an art than a science
so i i presented kind of my my
scientific view on
on what the choices are and the
expressive power of different choices
but uh in many ways kind of beyond that
i think it tends to be a bit more of an
art in designing these architectures
okay um and this um
yeah so this kind of getting to the
question uh in the chat about where do
we actually conduct concatenate the
conditioning this is kind of also a
design decision that needs to be kind of
chosen
um
for the problem and of course when
you're kind of designing architectures
you can use cross validation to help
guide your search as well
okay
so
that's it for the model uh now let's
talk a bit about the objective
so
we talked about the vanilla objective
before which is just the summation over
all of the tasks but often we want to
weight different tasks differently so we
may want an objective that looks more
like this
where there is a wait for each task
and
you want to kind of
upgrade or down wait some tasks
in various ways
now the key question is now how do you
actually choose these task weights
um one
way to do it is just to manually choose
the task weights based on what you find
to work well
or based on some sort of priority if you
care more about one task than another
task
unfortunately manually
isn't always a great choice because you
have to um it's a manual process so
there's also a number of methods that
have
suggested ideas to actually adjust wi
automatically and actually dynamically
adjust them throughout training in order
to lead to a better optimization or
um
or try to optimize things in a way
depending on the application
so how do we actually kind of go about
dynamically adjusting them throughout
training
so
there are various heuristics for doing
this so um one heuristic that has been
fairly popular in the literature is to
encourage gradients to have similar
magnitudes this is what was proposed in
this grad norm paper uh in
2018 uh and it's been fairly popular and
seems to work fairly well uh
kind of guided by the intuition that if
the gradients have similar magnitudes
then no one task will be dominating
uh but it's also a heuristic so there
are other approaches that are i think
less heuristic and a bit more principled
one of these is to use task uncertainty
uh and this actually i think is a pretty
interesting idea i guess it's somewhat
elegant in how this actually turns out
so
um this is a paper in 2018 and they what
they talked about is if you want to
weight your different tests differently
um the intuition is that you may want to
wait tasks that you're uncertain about
higher so that you can try to decrease
your uncertainty for those tasks
so the way that they formulated this is
they assume that you have
basically
a distribution of y given x for each
task i
and they set this to be equal to
the
a gaussian distribution if you're doing
regression of with a mean that's equal
to
the output of your neural network
and a variance
that is also a learned vector and it's
going to be a learned vector per task
and this is what's going to be your task
uncertainty
and this is also what's called
homoscedastic uncertainty if you want to
know a
a cool term um and this is in contrast
to
the typical uncertainty that you might
have with the neural network that is
kind of outputting a different
uncertainty for each data point that's
what's known as heteroskedastic uh
uncertainty in this case it's
homoscedastic uncertainty in the sense
that it's the same for all data points
within a task
but it's going to be kind of
representing the uncertainty for that
specific task that's why we have an
index of i here this is going to be
learned
and it turns out if that if you
essentially minimize the
um
if you minimize the log likelihood of
your data points or sorry the negative
log likelihood
of
each of
your data points for each of the tasks
you can show that basically
this objective is proportional to
a sum over
1 over
sigma squared
times l i
plus log of sigma i
so what this is saying is that basically
this corresponds exactly to wi
and for tasks that you have a higher
uncertainty because you have a higher
standard dev standard deviation or a
higher variance you should
um
the um
you should weight those um
you should weight those differently
essentially
um
yeah so if you have higher
yeah higher uncertainty you should um
it should actually sorry smaller
insurance should lead to a higher task
weight and
uh
and more uncertainty you should actually
have a smaller task weight
um and i guess the thing that i find
nice about this is it actually
kind of falls directly out of maximum
likelihood training right here
do you have a question
yeah hi uh i was wondering how we get
the variance
yeah so this is actually this term right
here is actually learned so it's just
going to be a vector of learned
parameters so in addition to learning
theta
um and maybe i should actually have just
written this here in addition to
learning theta you're also going to be
optimizing each of these variance
vectors
uh sorry it's the variance of like the
weights or something or
um
it is the variance of the
of this distribution right here so this
is a distribution over the label given
the input
and the mean of this distribution is the
output of this neural network and the
variance is given by
sigma squared i
does that make sense
uh i'm still kind of lost but i don't
have a more precise questions asked for
now
okay
yes
right so in the paper they also derive
this for um
for a like a cross-entry loss as well um
this this derivation is specific to
using like regression problems for mean
squared error for example or um assuming
a gaussian distribution
the um but yeah if you if you have
discrete labels then you could also
derive
a version of this as well
hey uh so um from what i understand
you're saying that you know if you're
not trying to have these learned ways
for uh your multiple task losses that's
because you can understand that as being
explicitly taken out of gaussian
language
and distribution for the player for your
um
um and that's how you think of
kinetically derived
hi so i i just want to make sure i
understand um basically like on the high
level this makes sense but where does
the um
what part of the equation is related to
the variables that we have like the most
uncertainty about i'm trying to see
where why where we see mathematically
that those are weighted more
yeah so actually i i think i messed up
the description a little bit here so
the basically this task uncertainty this
is um
this is given by
this kind of sigma squared variable
variance or the cost uncertainty or like
that's basically equivalent in this case
they're
um they're basically
yeah so
if the the variance over the
um over the data distribution of y given
x
all right all right and then um
we see that it's weighted more we're in
the derivation
um so this is where i messed up my
description it's actually weighted less
so less okay that makes more sense and
that's why it's logged right in the last
equation
that's why it's one over um sorry it's
one over oh yes one over two yeah so all
right that makes a little bit of sense
it's less weighted
okay
all right so as the variance increases
in this case as well is uncertainty
increases because we don't know what's
going on there we waited a little bit
less
yeah exactly okay okay all right i can
roll with that thank you
yeah
cool okay um
now i think i'm going to need to
erase some of this to go on to the next
point or maybe i should find a better
way to do this next time
so
this is one way to to produce the
weights of the
of your loss function
uh and this is actually been pretty
successful in practice and it's one
that's um it's a method that actually
i've seen pretty strong performance
now and used is a pretty strong baseline
that people have used in a number of
papers even now
um
another approach for
finding these weights was to instead
take a perspective of multi-objective
optimization and try to aim for
monotonic improvement towards a pareto
optimal solution
and what i mean by this uh i guess first
i'll just kind of define what i mean by
kind of pareto optimal
um and in particular what this means is
that uh
first a set of parameters will dominate
another set of parameters if its loss
is lower or equal to
the loss of the other set of parameters
for all of the tasks
and its overall objective is not equal
so basically what this is saying is that
uh say you plot negative the negative
loss for one task and the negative loss
for another task um ideally you want to
be kind of somewhere around here uh that
will lead to the lowest that means that
you have the lowest loss for both of the
tasks
then
um if you have one
vector here
then
that is a to b and basically anything
in this region right here
will dominate theta b
um including things that are on this
line and everything that's not in this
region will not dominate uh
theta a theta b sorry so if theta a is
somewhere over here then that means that
it dominates theta b
and the reason why i'm saying this is
that you
can define
a theta as being pareto optimal if there
exists no other theta that dominates
theta star
so basically if you have
a number of
parameter vectors in different positions
in your
plot
maybe these are all the kind of
parameter vectors that you um are able
to find
then the ones that are pareto optimal
are the ones that are
basically on this curve and this curve
is what's called the
the pareto front
and this is relevant because basically
all the points that are
if you're at a pareto optimal point then
that means that improving for one task
will always require worsening the
performance for another task and so
reaching a pareto optimal solution is
usually something that's uh
that's good because it means that you've
at least gotten to the optimal for one
task and with regard to that optimal um
all the other tasks are at kind of a
local maximum as well
okay um and then the last thing that you
could do for weighting tasks differently
is to optimize for the worst case task
class
and this looks like an objective like
this where you're
optimizing over your parameters and
taking the the worst case i and only
optimizing for that one
so this will basically take the
take the task that's performing the
worst and only optimize that loss and
the reason why this makes sense is that
if you want to be kind of
robust to the tasks that you might see
at test time um if you imagine that you
might be seeing kind of the worst case
task at test time
then this is a good thing to do
or um this also connects to fairness so
if different tasks correspond to
different groups of your population then
it might be best to optimize for the one
that's doing the worst to try to ensure
that they all reach some baseline level
of performance
um and so this has been used in like the
distributional robustness um literature
and in a range of other uh groups of
literature as well
okay
yeah so uh i have a question for b and
like i think also related to d point
here um so for b i didn't understand
like if if a task has lower higher
uncertainty wouldn't you want to
sorry train it more and then relating to
d i think doesn't be go against b as in
like
uh in indeed we are trying to train
tasks that we are certain about whereas
indeed we are trying to
train more on tasks that are not robust
yeah so the kind of when you would use
these different things depends on the
application that you're considering
um
task uncertainty corresponds to kind of
a maximum likelihood objective whereas
this ladder objective corresponds to
kind of a a robustness objective which
is just different
um if you really care about
all of your tasks
like treating them fairly then
optimizing for the worst case loss um is
one thing that makes more sense than
trying to just maximize your likelihood
um whereas if you're an application
where uh fairness with regard to tasks
doesn't necessarily matter that much and
you just want to optimize overall
performance then one of these um one of
these earlier approaches might
make more sense
[Music]
if you have a regression task then
sometimes it may just have um
numbers in a larger magnitude
so is there any you're standardizing a
loss or something they're all in the
same ballpark that's one question
and my second question is in the plots
in green on the right the left hand side
plot has negative l2 a negative l1 is an
intentional
yeah this is intentional on the plots
basically i wanted it to be such that
things away from the origin are better
and that makes it easier to see this um
this kind of curve
the theta is not better than
so the origin is um
the origin isn't you'd rather be at like
one of these points than than be at the
bottom
yeah so you want to make sure that your
losses are are on similar scales and if
they're not then then this won't make
sense and this won't work uh and
typically in like fairness applications
for example you are optimizing the same
objective for different groups
okay i'm actually going to move on um
to the next slide just for time uh
because i want to make sure we get
through the case study let's talk about
optimization so
uh we'll really just to cover the basics
here um when you have this objective the
approach that you might take to optimize
it is to
sample a mini batch of tasks um from
your set of tasks if you have a
relatively small number of tasks then
you may want to just sample
just sample all of the tasks
then sample a mini batch of data points
for each task
uh so you'll take the the trading data
for that task and sample a mini batch
for from that data set
then compute the loss for that mini
batch using the
the loss function and using that mini
batch
and then
take this the loss for the mini batch um
well for each of the mini batches and
back propagate the loss into theta to
compute the gradient
and then once you have the gradient use
your favorite neural network optimizer
such as atom to update your neural
network
and what this does is that it uh
essentially encourages your your model
to
to consider data from
multiple different tasks at every mini
batch
um it ensures that the costs are sampled
uniformly regardless of whether or not
you have a lot more data for one task
than for another task
uh
and also as was mentioned before if you
have a regression problem it's good to
make sure that your task labels are on
the skin scale if they're not on the
same scale then you're essentially going
to be putting a weight in front of the
loss functions
that would be equivalent to putting the
upgrading the losses that have a larger
scale
okay
so that's the basics of optimizing
now um a couple of the challenges that
come up in multitask learning uh one
challenge is negative transfer and what
this means is that uh sometimes when you
actually train tasks together in a
single architecture that actually
performs worse than if you train
independent networks
um and so an example of this if you look
at a multi-task version of the c4100
benchmark
and you look at some recent approaches
uh the
uh training and independent network gets
67.7 and this actually does better
than a model that is
that only has one that is basically a
shared um base and one task specific
fully connected layer um also another
kind of multi-head architecture does
worse than independent training um and
this this kind of cross-stitch
architecture which is a fancier
architecture also does worse than
independent training so this is an
example where we see negative transfer
with these
three architectures compared to an
independent model
um why does this happen
this can happen for a few different
reasons it can happen for optimization
challenges caused by kind of
interference between different gradients
it's also maybe that different tasks may
learn at different rates and maybe one
task learns a lot more quickly and uses
up a lot of the capacity before the
other task is
is being learned
it may also be an issue of limited
representational capacity it's often the
case that multi-task networks need more
capacity than the sync their single task
counterpoints uh this can also have to
do with the the optimization challenges
before because if you have a larger
network it may be easier to optimize
um and changing these two things
increasing capacity
changing the optimization or changing
the architecture in some way can
alleviate issues of negative transfer
um and if you do have negative transfer
uh kind of the key thing that you can do
is to share less across tasks
uh and of course this also isn't just a
binary decision you can share more
parameters you can share less parameters
uh but there's also um
another thing you could do is to
do soft parameter sharing
so you could have different task
specific parameters theta i
and then encourage those task specific
parameters to be more similar to each
other using a loss that looks like this
that it essentially minimizes the norm
of the difference of those different
task parameters
and this would be similar to basically
taking a taking two independently
trained networks and encouraging the
weights to be similar to one another
through a loss that looks like this
um so this is kind of another design
choice that can go into your your
architecture
and kind of one rule of thumb is that if
you're seeing a negative transfer then
it could be helpful to share less or use
soft parameter sharing or have fewer
parameters that are shared
um this allows for
soft parameters trying allows for more
fluid degrees of parameter sharing but
it could be also yet another set of
design decisions and hyper parameters
and in practice i i typically see hard
parameter sharing used more than this
form of soft parameter training
um and then the second challenge that
you might see is overfitting uh and it
may be that you're actually not sharing
enough of the weights of your network
um multi-test learning can be
essentially viewed as a form of
regularization where other tasks are
regularizing the learning of the um
of learning another task
and so
if you find that it seems like it's
overfitting a lot then it could actually
be beneficial to share more of the
parameters um or put
more weight on on parameter sharing
okay
do you have a question
yes i understand how you uh talked about
combining the losses of different tasks
in the first lecture how do you combine
different accuracies
right so when you train neural networks
typically you use if you have discrete
labels you typically use cross entropy
loss um
rather than accuracy because that's um
accuracy isn't really a differentiable
uh metric
you have when you have a multi-task plus
a multi-task or
task
and you you you report a 67 accuracy is
that like average across the task so is
multitask itself a task
yeah so um the accuracy number is that i
was reporting for cfar that's averaged
across the tasks
um use oftentimes is also useful just to
report the individual task accuracies as
well
do you have a question
um
in the independent network did you just
like claim
like 100 different networks for each
kind of category is that what they were
doing
um so in this case it was actually 10
different tasks that corresponded to
some of the higher level classes that
are in this r 100 data set yeah
okay
cool so we're short on time so i'm going
to skip the break but hopefully the
questions have been a reasonable break
and let's go straight into the case
study uh real world multitask learning
and then we probably won't get to the
transfer learning but we'll we'll have
an opportunity to cover that uh in a
future lecture
um so
the case study that i'm going to cover
is this paper that was uh came out in
2019 that's actually a paper describing
um
a way to rank videos for serving them on
as youtube recommendations
uh and so the goal is basically to
figure out what you want to show the
user
in this kind of part of the i guess it's
all all this part of the side panel on
youtube
um
for a given user
uh and they they mentioned that there's
a number of different conflicting
objectives when making recommendations
uh they wanted to rate videos that they
wanted to kind of
recommend videos that the users will
rate highly
also videos that the users will share
with other users
and also videos that the user will
actually watch for a reasonable period
of time
another challenge that comes up is that
there's also some amount of feedback so
the user may have also watched um a
video because it was recommended uh and
if it wasn't recommended they wouldn't
have watched that and so this is also
another challenge that comes up in these
recommendation systems that makes it
more difficult to leverage data when the
recommendat when the recommendation
system was actually in the loop of that
data collection this isn't a problem
that they address in this work but this
is a problem that can be addressed with
some of the reinforcement learning
techniques that will be talked about
that we'll talk about later in the
course
um so the way that they set this up is
the input is what the user is currently
watching on the query video
and some set of user features
for that user
and then with this input they then
generate a few hundred candidate videos
they then rank these candidate videos
and then serve the top ranking videos to
the user
um the candidate videos they pooled
videos from multiple different candidate
generation algorithms this wasn't the
focus of the paper the focus of the
paper
was really the second step right here
although the the candidate generation
process different algorithms were like
matching topics of the query video
looking at videos most frequently
watched alongside the query video and
other algorithms
and then the ranking part was the
central topic of this paper
so the ranking problem
again kind of the input is the query
video also the candidate video that
they're considering
and the user and the context features
and then the model output is some score
that relates to engagement and
satisfaction with the input candidate
video
uh so engagement might be things like
binary classification tasks like uh
clicks on the video um
like numbers of clicks uh regression
tasks like the
time spent watching the video
and satisfaction scores maybe
a binary classification task like
predicting whether they would click like
for that video and also a regression
task such as rating the video through a
survey
uh and then they wait they use a
weighted combination of engagement and
satisfaction predictions to produce a
ranking score for that candidate video
um and i found it interesting that
actually the the weights for this score
were actually manually tuned um for the
algorithm to produce this corresponding
ranking score
um one question
we're maybe a little bit low on time so
maybe we won't discuss this right now
but i encourage you to think about
whether this objective is reasonable um
for producing recommendations to a user
and what some of the issues
um what issues might come up with these
kinds of metrics as well
this i think is especially relevant
right now because uh as kind of
technology's really
really engaging people's attention more
and more this may not actually be a
desirable outcome
when uh there are other things that we
want the user to spend their time on and
their attention on
so i'd encourage you to think about this
and really to think about this when
building any real-world machine learning
system
okay um the architecture they
their kind of basic option was the
multi-head architecture that we talked
about before where you have multiple
bottom layers that are processing the
input features in the embedding
and also a couple task specific layers
for engagement
and um
and the other metrics
and they found that this can harm
learning when the correlation between
different tasks is low because they had
like multiple different shared bottom
layers that may not actually be good to
share information between
so what they proposed in this work was
to use a form of soft parameter sharing
where
they had a
mixture of experts
that was gated for different tasks
and basically what this corresponded to
is they wanted to allow different parts
of the network to specialize for
different subtasks
so they have different expert neural
networks that are written here this
architecture on the left shows two
different expert layers expert one and
expert two
they then decide which expert to use for
a given input and a given task
so this is given by a softmax function
and then they compute features from the
selected expert
and then eventually compute the output
based off of
what expert was used for which task and
also the features from that expert
and then in their experiments they
implemented this uh with tensorflow on
tpus
they trained the models in temporal
order as the as they got data um it
turns out that you have a lot of data on
youtube and so they were basically
running training continuously to consume
all of the newly arrived data
and then they kind of looked at offline
metrics such as area under the curve and
squared error metrics they also did
online a b testing in comparison with
the production system
with live metrics and uh
and in the setting computational
efficiency matters a lot
uh in the results they found that with
this mixture of experts multi-gated
mixture effects model they were seeing
um actually pretty significant increases
in engagement and satisfaction
um based on the candidates that were
ranked from this algorithm
um and they also found that they were
seeing kind of different experts used in
diverse ways for different tasks so for
example expert seven was used a lot for
satisfaction task four and expert two
was used a lot for satisfaction task two
into satisfaction task three
okay
um cool so that's kind of a kind of real
world example of a multitask learning
system um
to kind of respect your time i'll
won't go through the transfer learning
we'll cover that in a future
lecture and
i'll wrap up by saying uh
i guess
we got through this this first point
which is to understand some of the key
design decisions when building
multi-task learning systems
and i'll leave you with a few reminders
for those of you that want to stick
around i'll continue to answer questions
but you're also
if you need to go i understand that as
well and i'll see you on monday